I would like to talk to you about the
number five and the thing that I like
most about the number five is that there
are only five platonic solids
this is a regular polygon it's a regular
triangle and it has the same number of
triangles meeting at each corner the
definition of a platonic solid is a
shape where you've got sort of different
sides to the shape but all of the sides
are the same shape that shape is a
regular kind of polygon so like a square
where all the sides are the same length
and the angles are all the same and
every corner looks the same so those are
the conditions and this is in fact
called a tetrahedron it's like a pyramid
but it's got a triangular base not a
square base so a tetrahedron is four
triangles this is the octahedron it has
eight ops eight triangular faces so if I
get two of those and stick them together
you'll see that I also get the same
corner everywhere else and this is an
octahedron so unlike our tetrahedron
this has four triangles meeting at each
corner and this is one of my favorite
platonic solids this is called an
icosahedron you can see every single
corner has got five triangles meeting at
it and all of the faces of triangles and
in fact you get 20 triangles so this is
an icosahedron this one over here
my mother's pops well Brady what's that
that is a cube yeah it's a hexahedron
well done so hexahedron has six square
faces so i'm happy with that and i'll
put a cube on my list and that is six
squares at this point i would jump to
Pentagon's I don't have any Pentagon's
unfortunately but you can fit three
Pentagon's around a point this is the
dodecahedron dough deck means 12 it has
twelve Pentagon faces and at each of 30
X we have three Pentagon's
okay so we're going to show that there
are only five possible regular solids so
let's imagine we are you we're looking
at a shape that has triangular faces
okay so it has to have at least three
let's think of a corner there we go try
to get that right so they have let's
imagine this corner here and around this
corner are three regular triangles now
we've got this gap here
here's a big gap a space if you glue
this side to this side it's going to be
a concave shape and that will actually
be three triangles around a point that
will be your tetrahedron let's add
another triangle let's make it look like
this
so now we've got four triangles we've
got this gap again now if we glue these
sides together this gap four triangles
around a point well that will be your
octahedron that will make up octahedron
fine let's draw another triangle in here
so now we've got five triangles around a
point glue it together here's a little
missing gap here grow it together and
this will make your icosahedron five
triangles around a point if you tried to
keep going if you try six triangles
around a point though all you get is a
flat object it's as a flat piece of
paper it's not concave it's not a shape
so that's as far as you can go seven
eight you can't add any more triangles
all right let's do the squares this has
three squares around a point there we go
these are all 90 degrees 90 degrees
there's a missing gap here glue it
together this side glued to this side
and you'll get your cube if you try and
add a fourth Square to it you'll get 360
degrees you'll get a flat shape again
you know point let's try the Pentagon's
that's all we have to do Pentagon's I
will do my best
Pentagon's I start to draw I'm the ass
I'm a mathematician rather than artist
so I made just leave it there I think
I'm gonna have to I'm going to struggle
on this but if I draw Pentagon's but a
Pentagon has an angle of 108 degrees you
can fit three around a point if you fit
three around a point that would add up
to 324 degrees and you'd have a little
gap and you can glue it together and if
you do it you'll end up with three
Pentagon's around a point that's a
dodecahedron
you can't fit for around a point the
angles are too big so let's move on
let's try the hexagons heck
chickens have an angle of 120 degrees if
you try three hexagons around a point
that will add up to 360
ok I'll draw those he says let's draw
three hexagons around a point each one
has 120 degrees 120 degrees 120 degrees
it adds up to 360 s flat it makes a flat
shape it's not it's not a concave shape
it's not a solid after that if you're
looking at seven sided shapes eight
sided shapes there's two the angles are
too big and they don't make regular
solids at all Katie I think the viewers
are going to have two questions here's
the first question
where does a sphere fit into all of this
a sphere isn't a platonic solid because
it doesn't technically have faces I
guess in some sense the sphere is kind
of the limit of having more and more
faces like if you get enough faces
eventually the faces are all of size
zero but it's not it's not counted as as
a solid of any shape because it's not
got kind of individual faces that are a
shape okay and the other question
they're going to have is where can I get
some of those cool magnet toys the these
are amazing and this called poly drawn
they do like a clippie together version
but this is a magnetic version which is
like the the Ferrari of polygons and
while we're using brand names I think
this is really nice they do sell
Pentagon's and if anyone wants to get me
a very nice presence in Pentagon's would
be much appreciated but as it stands I
own squares and triangles
and the drive